[Music]
okay
next up we have gordon shotwell who's
going to be talking to us about why
technical debt is a social problem
hi um thank you so much for coming uh so
the
title of this talk is technical that is
the social problem and the reason i
wanted to
give that is i think unfortunately um
our community has
a reputation especially in industry as a
language that has a high amount of
technical debt
i think this is actually a fairly major
problem in terms of adopting
um r in a lot of contexts where it
hasn't been adopted before
and as a community we need to take this
seriously and work on it
and i've often found myself in the
position where
i was kind of coming into a team or an
organization
and i knew sort of what to do to pay
back technical debt on that team
but i didn't actually have any sort of
decision-making power
over what we worked on so i had to sort
of learn to be a little bit more
strategic
in terms of building these more robust
solutions and the main
insight that i had through this process
was that it's um
not a technical problem really it's a
social problem
um technical debt for those of you who
are not familiar basically
all of the little shortcuts that we take
developing things
especially under time pressure that make
the products less stable
or less easy to maintain over the long
term the idea is that eventually you're
going to pay that back
that's the idea it's really the practice
and when you look at the actual
artifacts that we call technical debt
um they're almost always social
artifacts and i think they fall into
uh two main categories they're a failure
of consideration
or a failure of communication sorry the
other way around on the slide
read the slides don't listen to me so
communication is really you know just
what you think about it it's how we
communicate technically with other
people
um so the things that fall into this
category are like
documentation uh which is how we
communicate use
and purpose tests which is how we
communicate
correctness like what the software is
meant to do
precisely and then also things like
code style and project organization how
easy it is to find the thing that you're
looking for
in a code project and how easy it is to
understand that thing to actually just
physically read it
so those are all quite obviously i think
things that happen between other people
we can't judge whether documentation
is good or bad without knowing whether
another human being
who's relevant to us understands it
right there's no like
perfect communication that we can
transmit to the world
what matters is whether somebody
understands us
consideration are all the things that
have to do with how well
your software handles things that are
not problems that you have
right whenever we're developing software
it does a really good job
of handling the problem that's in front
of us the problem that we're thinking
about
but we can judge software as being kind
of um
good or bad robust or not based on how
it sort of handles a broader spectrum of
people
right so these are things like the code
isn't robust right
someone throws some arguments at it that
you didn't really think about that
weren't something that you would think
to throw at
at a function and it all falls down um
it can't be updated easily maybe there's
a lot of repetition and things need to
be updated in many places right
it doesn't solve the problems of future
people or even just the problems of
other people today
and then it has things like fragile
dependency structures or maybe it
works on some scales but it doesn't work
at all on larger scales
so all of these are basically about how
good our imagination is when we're
developing these products right
how how well we can think about all the
different things that somebody might
conceivably throw at that
and how skilled we are at putting people
putting ourselves in other people's
shoes
to understand how they're going to
relate to that problem what they're
going to try to solve with it
and how they're going to try to solve it
so again these are really
social problems right it's not so much
that there's like a perfect dependency
structure
it's not that there's a perfect kind of
robustness
it has to do with how we're considering
the needs of other people in our
organization
and the people who will join in the
future
so um this also gives us some insight
into why it's so difficult to pay
technical debt back right
because when you think when you realize
that actually this is a problem between
two people
you sort of bring in this other insight
which is that people are really really
kind of fickle and biased right
so some of the biases that i think you
encounter so one of them is is status
quo
bias this is of course the 1970s uk rock
band status quo
i'm sure it's familiar to you um so this
is just that uh
when you're when you're working with a
system for long enough
right you've paid the price of learning
that system and you've kind of gotten
used to the pain you feel
when you use it right so it's sort of
all those things kind of disappear for
you
and so you have this sort of bias that
you kind of like the way it is
right and you're not going to really be
that interested in changing it you're
going to sort of
overestimate the cost of change because
you've already learned the existing
thing
and nobody's learned the new things or
you're going to have to do some work to
learn a new thing
the second bias is the ikea effect and
this is a
one of my favorite i love this picture
um because you really tell us she likes
that chair
um so when you have a when you build
something from ikea basically you
overestimate
how good it is so you put something
together yourself and you kind of invest
a little bit of your ego into that thing
and since you're sort of
your ego is your favorite thing like
suddenly that thing becomes way better
than everything else
i think this is a big part of why um
programmers tend to like
like building their own databases right
because like even if it's worse
objectively than the database you could
buy like you built it
so you sort of are like there's some
pride that goes along with that
so similarly whenever you're trying to
replace something usually you're
replacing something that somebody
in your organization who's still there
has built right so they overvalue it
and lastly it's the the parenting effect
um this is my daughter's first
experience with spinach
and so this is uh when you watch
something grow up you forgive its messes
right you
you forgive the problems because you
knew kind of you sort of see how it sort
of progressed over time
and you're like well it's so much better
than it used to be right like you know
they can do so much
this system can do so much more than it
used to be so much easier to use than it
used to be
and you sort of forget about like that
actually right now it's it's got some
problems
um so all of these things together i'm
sure we could think of other biases but
all of these things together means that
um it's never a fair contest right
whenever you're trying to pay back
technical debt
um it's not that people are gonna
rationally evaluate like which one is
objectively a little bit better
right when you're replacing these things
you have to do much much better
in order to get over these kinds of
humps that you find within an
organization
and the goal i think for doing that is
to try to build delightful
products um so something where uh this
is sort of similar to how we relate with
external users of products right we want
to build something that actually people
get
excited about when they use that they
really sort of it's a joyful experience
when they use this thing
and that can mean a lot of different
things for me like some of the things i
really focus on
are that it sets up in a single step so
like install.packages right there you
only have to call one thing and the
setup is complete
there's a clear obvious first problem um
there's a way to kind of a clear way to
get from the obvious first problem
to something quite complicated to be a
master of that system
um and then it has um
sort of help resources and it's it
doesn't break right it doesn't sort of
just randomly stop working
so one of the things one of the products
i really love that fulfills all these
things is our markdown
um because especially it sort of gives
you something that like right away
here's the easy thing that you can do
right now but
down the road you know you can just
really take over all
publishing you know like you can publish
all the websites all the books
right using the same framework and
there's a smooth path to that
so building delightful products that's
the goal and if you do that then i think
you can kind of overcome those biases
how do you do how do you build
delightful products well i have a
three-step plan for you
so the first one is to find the right
beachhead which is to pick your first
battle
in this process of paying back technical
debt and pick that correctly
second is to separate users and
maintainers and to treat these internal
products more like you treat
external facing products and lastly
empathize with the debtor
so a beach head um for those of you who
are not familiar with the military
things
um is like when you're invading a
country you like have like a little
staging area that you have to take first
right and it's not about winning the war
but it's about like
putting yourself in a position where you
can you know deploy your resources and
you know get supply lines and all that
stuff
um so finding the right beachhead is
very much about like picking the right
project and so this is a a picture of um
a piece of
codebase that i was working on at secure
when i
was for starting and each of these is an
r script the dots is an r script and
each of the lines is a sourcing
relationship between
the script and another one and so here
at the time
was a very small data science team and
has grown a lot so this was a kind of
type of of way of sharing code that
works really pretty well if you're like
four or five people it works less well
if you're like 25 or 30 people
um and there's a sort of natural
tendency
from for myself to like look at this and
say i just need to replace this with a
package right i need to take over all of
this code and put it into one
thing and that's going to fail right
because
there's no way that i'm going to be able
to really understand what each of these
things does
and there's no way that actually i even
know that a lot of these things need to
be around at all
right so you have to be strategic about
what you're picking which of these am i
going to
use to give me kind of something which i
know i'm going to be able to accomplish
and it's also going to build trust in
the organization
so some of these things i think is
really important to focus on small
contained projects and something that
you can do
really really well at right you're
trying to knock it out of the park
and it's easier to do that with a
baseball than like a bag of jello or
you know an elephant or something right
so you want to have something that's
small because
mostly what's going to happen is people
are going to judge it based on the delta
not so much the overall value so it's
better to do
really really well in an area of limited
scope than just a little bit well
in an area of big scope it's good if
it's a orphan or greenfield project like
there's nobody in the organization who's
super attached to what it how it's like
now
and if there's external pressure coming
from outside of your team that's also
really great because nobody likes to
respond to that so if you can take that
on
it's really good so in my case what we
picked there was the database access
functions right they were small i could
understand them well
and we were responding to some external
pressure from our infrastructure
team to sort of change how we were
storing and distributing credentials
so find the right beachhead put yourself
in a position where you can solve this
small problem
and solve it well so that you can move
forward what this will allow you to do
is develop like trust within the
organization
it'll allow you to build up the emphasis
social and sort of technical
infrastructure that you need to solve
these problems like a ci process or just
learning how to do code review with
other people
the second main point is to separate
users and maintainers
and this is in order to build delightful
products you need somebody who is
defining what delight means and you need
somebody who's trying to
make the product do that right so in
other words you need a user and you need
a maintainer
so ideally every system in your in your
team or your organization should have a
written down list
of who is a maintainer of that product
and everybody else is a user
these two groups abide by a basic and
holy contract
that contract is that users get coddled
and maintainers get opinions
right so you have to pick one of these
things we all want to kind of sit
between these like we want to be coddled
and we also want to have opinions we
want to make these decisions but we
don't really want to deal with all the
consequences that might happen down the
road from those decisions
we don't want to write the code we don't
want to document it or write tests
what this says is basically we're not
doing that anymore with these
these sort of low technical debt
problems we're going to have
maintainers we're going to have users
and if you're a user and you want to be
a maintainer
you know you're welcome to but you're
going to get all of the other stuff that
goes along with that to make sure that
this product is delightful
so being a good maintainer means you're
responsible for making it delightful
that's your goal right you want to make
this product really really good
really really easy to use you want to
make it a joy
with that you have the responsibility
and the authority to do that
right so you're the decision maker over
what that product does and how it does
it right you decide
whether it's how it's going to
accomplish this goal and you kind of
judge yourself based on whether you're
accomplished
accomplishing it so along with this
means that you don't kind of ask the
users to do your job for you
this comes up a lot for uh internal
products with documentation where so the
first time that we asked somebody to set
up a system and if the documentations
are wrong
documentation is wrong we ask that
person to fix the documentation
when usually actually they're the worst
person to document something because
they understand it the least
so this is sort of something where you
say like as a maintainer i'm going to do
all of this stuff to make sure that this
thing
is is really good and i'm not going to
make i'm not going to expect the user to
be able to do any of the things that
i should do being a good user is
basically the opposite of this right you
get to define what delight means
and importantly you have to sort of turn
off the part of your brain that can
understand computer systems really
really well so as developers
like it's tempting to basically be like
oh i have a bug with this system i don't
maintain
i'm going to go read the source code and
figure out what that bug is and that's
rarely a good use of your time
both because you have your own systems
to maintain and also because
you're not actually fixing the problem
for the the sort of like
lowest common denominator user right you
want the you want to have the feedback
be like
actually this was hard to use i had to
think hard to get this to set up
please fix that right that's not
delightful if i have to work too hard at
it
it's also good to ask about the problem
not the solution so rather than
proposing like you should change this
technical thing in your system
say like as a user i have this problem
right there's a reason why
product managers use that a lot it's a
really good way of phrasing it
um and it's just important to not be
embarrassed about complaining about
something
and to really try to never read source
code so a good sort of standard is
if you if you're asked to do like
documentation like you can
you can ask you can give code style
input and if people like say like we're
not talking about that that means you're
a user
um so for instance like sometimes i
start asking like
you know like some of these questions
and and then eventually they say like
you know i actually i'll start start
talking about something else and then
i say okay great i'm a user like you
know fix your docs
um so another sort of thing that comes
up frequently is like
i run an r package and i often get sort
of
requests from various different people
to put a function that they've written
into that our package and this might be
a perfectly good function that solves
the problem that's in front of them
but it might not be tested it might not
be consistent with the other functions
it might not be documented
um so if you do that too much you kind
of end up with this sort of package
right where you sort of like
you know you've made some progress like
you've lined them up
right but it's actually it's never going
to really do the job like doing the job
of building sort of a global system that
works well together and is intuitive and
easy to remember
it takes a lot of work right you
actually have to think hard about it
and unless you're a maintainer of this
this package
you're not really going to have the time
or attention to do that right
so the last uh point is um to empathize
with the debtor
and i think the important thing here is
is whenever you're um
uh doing these projects you kind of have
to like
remember that what you're doing is kind
of inherently
threatening and sort of insulting right
because you're saying to
somebody who has worked worked hard on
something right that
the thing that they've developed like
doesn't work anymore right or maybe it
never worked but it doesn't work anymore
um and that is really a problem because
you're also asking them to
to learn something and when people are
sort of threatened or afraid
it turns out that they can't learn
anything right that there's those two
parts of your
your mind like they they can't work
together so you need to have people be
kind of like
comfortable and feel supported and
understood
in order to get them to change and also
in order for you to learn from them
right because the existing
products like they're not all bad
they've done some good jobs right
so it's important to like to really like
try to take their perspective
um to understand like where they're
coming from why does this system do
things the way it does
and how can we kind of together make it
make it better
and then more often than not this is you
right like you're looking at your own
projects
from two years ago paying back technical
debt and you kind of don't want to look
at it
because you feel bad about yourself and
that's unpleasant
so you never fix the tests right like
you know so
so having this like i'm kind of using
this phrase to like talk about other
people but really a lot of the times
with
it's you right like you're the person on
the other side of this when you have
some other person coming in and saying
like
this doesn't work or you're looking at
your old stuff and it doesn't work um
and all this really applies in the same
way right like you're trying to learn a
new thing and if you feel threatened and
afraid
you're not gonna learn it right you're
just gonna kind of like whatever the
docs are fine
um so uh
um the there's this i don't know if
you're familiar with marie condo
um but she she has this thing where you
like if you're getting rid of your old
pants
like you pick up your pants and you say
you know thank you pants
like you know you covered my butt for a
lot you know like
you did a good job right and then that's
that helps you let go
because you sort of like these don't
look good on me anymore but thank you
so i really think that um one way of
doing developing this kind of
empathy is to look at technical data as
a good sign
and the reason it's a good sign is
because the only
reason you ever care about paying back
debt is if you haven't declared
bankruptcy
right so you know technical debt means
like i haven't declared technical or
regular bankruptcy right so there's
still something there
to work on right otherwise i just throw
it away
um so you can look at all these codes
sort of artifacts these things that you
know you're like oh this is awful this
this is really fragile it breaks all the
time it's hard to learn
um and sort of just remember that
actually this is um
the work of like thoughtful people who
are doing their
best with the knowledge and resources
that they have available to them
and that's really all we can ask of
people and similarly
the code the fact that you're looking at
that code or that product means that it
got you to the next step right it did
something
um and that even if that thing is just
basically
showing you what doesn't work right and
that's really all we can ask of these
products is just to
take us one step forward so that we can
like fix it right it's kind of a
constant process of just basically
fixing broken things
and then breaking new things that need
fixing later
so going back to this slide basically
sorry
i was not using a timer um going back to
this slide this
code base was developed at a time when
soaker was really kind of in a slight
like emergency like we really needed a
product to get to market
right and this did that right we have a
market leading identity product now
because of what this code did right even
it's a bit of a tangled mess like it got
us there and that's why i'm here
sort of talking about this so
um thank you that's that's all i really
have i think it's a sort of important
thing that we should focus on
we are hiring so please talk to me if
you would like to work on identity fraud
and i'm on twitter thank you
oh sorry that's wrong thank you gordon
uh we have time for maybe one question
uh regarding the user versus maintainer
roles what are tips for teams with
high turnover and then another question
is
oops where a team has a user that is
highly likely to become a future
maintainer
uh so for the turnover i think basically
turnover is good
because it the more you turn over you
have the more education
feedback you get so in that sense it's
important basically like
if you're able to manage this manage
high turnover that's a good sign that
you're able to
educate people quickly so that's
actually kind of like a beneficial thing
um for the maintainer user things um i
think kind of giving people like good
first projects is really helpful uh one
of the things that i think is i found
very helpful
um personally is if somebody else writes
tests for me
um so if you if you're if you're a like
senior person the best thing you can do
is write documentation or tests and have
a junior person
fill in the code like the code is
actually the easiest part
setting the expectations for what that
code needs to do is the hard part
great thank you very much thank you
you